behind me we've got a chart that we've
been looking at a lot
uh today at sky news showing you tax as
a percentage of gdp basically the tax
burden
uh in the uk and i suppose my question
is you know looking at this chart and
looking at how high the tax burden is
getting towards the end of the forecast
horizon
are you concerned about being the
chancellor with the highest
tax burden of any chance of going all
the way back to the 1960s
and roy jenkins does that concern you at
all
well ed i guess what the chart your
chart doesn't show is
all the other chancellors if any of them
have had pandemics to deal with
uh you know we haven't had a pandemic
like this in over 100 years
and so i think that's remember that's
why we're having this conversation
that's the problem that we're grappling
with and
unsurprisingly you know when you've had
a shock like that
and then when you've had a response the
one and the likes of which we've done i
think any of those other chancellors
probably have ever had to do as much
fiscal support for
the country as i have had to i think
it's reasonable to expect that what we
have to do in response to all of those
things is going to be a bit different
to what's happened in the past but what
i would say is
what are we doing what are we doing with
those taxes what we're doing is funding
strong public services
people elected us because we told them
we were the party of public services we
were going to invest in the nhs
in schools and we were also going to
invest in projects across the country to
level up opportunity
that's what we want to get on and
deliver during this parliament and we
also want to be responsible with the
public finances for the reasons i set
out
and it's because of those reasons that
i've take taken the two decisions i've
made today
and i do believe they are the right
decisions for the country
and for the economy